Okay, first of all, let me say thank you from SNAD for the scientific help on Apollo
16.
I personally think that you all did a very credible job in helping the science support room
and pre-flighting to get all the experiments ready to prepare the crew and the flight for Apollo 16.
I think that looking back at it now, we can say we had a very successful mission that
we attained tremendous amount of information from the flight.
I know that the rock boxes back there at the curatorial facility are bursting at their
seams and the geologists are going to have a lot to do.
I think also that because of the problems that arose and the necessity to change the
flight plan that you responded quite well to get the maximum science out of the time that
we had available.
I realize that in all of our flights, there hasn't been one flight yet that ran according
to schedule and I am very sure that Apollo 17 will be in the same boat that we will have
to change things real time to get the maximum science out of the mission.
And I think the response on this flight was superb.
Now today, the briefing here is in two parts and for two purposes.
First of all, I like each principal investigator to briefly describe the results so far
obtained from his work.
This is to sort of educate the crew on what we obtained so far from Apollo 16 so that
they might have information along that line.
Also I like to have him describe any anomalies that might have occurred that we do not
know about now.
And second, then we like to have the PI with the crew working with them to answer, have
the crew answer any questions that might still be puzzling him so that he might further
his analysis of the data.
We have a lot of people to go through today, a lot of science to cover so we like to keep
each briefing short and we don't want to cover things that are pretty well that are general
knowledge as of today.
And we can start right out.
This one is Palmer Dial, Lunar Service Magnetometer.
After each experimenter describes this experiment, we'll have questions Palmer so we'll,
we can ask the crew any questions after your particular talk.
There's a mic right over there.
You may set Stan anything you want to do.
The, I guess the main functions of both instruments went nominally, they, I'd like to
cover both the portable and the surface, if that's acceptable, the, the, the all-step
instrument, the surface magnetometer that you deployed first looked like it went according
to a plan, the field that we measured as soon as it was turned on, I think it was turned
on about 15 minutes or so after you deployed it was 230 gamma and in a downward direction.
And at that particular time, that was the highest field that we'd ever measured on the,
on the lunar surface.
The, the calibration of the instrument went straight forward.
We did do a gradient determination of the field at the site, that the site survey as we
call it, function normally, the, it's thermal control subsystem is the best that we've put
on the moon so far.
We have a delta T from lunar day to lunar night of 51 degrees centigrade, which is a factor
of two better than our Apollo 12 thermal subsystem.
The leveling of the device was, I noticed in the photograph yesterday that the bubble
level was right in the center of rain, the level sensors that we have are accurate to a quarter
of a degree and they show that, that the instrument is level to one degree accuracy right
now.
The instrument has new sensors in it, these are more stable and it's really the first chance
we have of doing network type measurements of the fields on the moon.
We do see whole, we have seen simultaneous data now from 15 and 16, we see the magnetic
fields due to any currents that are driven in the entire lunar sphere and for the first time
experimentally, we have always made that assumption that we've got an instrument that's
setting on a, at one point on the sphere and that we're looking at the properties of
a whole sphere and we had some experimental evidence that that were the case now we
have unambiguously shown with this second instrument that, that is indeed the case in the
assumption is correct that we are looking at a whole spherical response of the moon.
They mean you're seeing 80 currents all the way through the moon.
We're seeing 80 currents that go travel around the whole sphere but with these new sensors
now and with long-term data, what we're going to try and do is look as you say right
at the center of the moon as they go all the way through.
Now that's what we're waiting for during the lunar night is a nice step function and
a long term both before and after so we can see these currents diffuse right to the
center of the moon.
The other thing that I think that is unique about this instrument is that now we have
a chance to look at the, as musical variations in connectivity.
We can not only look at radial dependence of the electrical connectivity and calculated
temperature but now we can look at the, as musical or angular variations between the
Apollo 15 and Apollo 16 site and those, and that spread is far enough so that we ought
to be able to extrapolate those measurements to a great circle around the whole moon
which was as musical dependence.
The portable magnetometer was really exciting.
First of all, the field, the first field I think you measured was 180 gamma down and in
the calie it looked like that all the fields were in essence pointed in a downward direction
and at the outset side it was 230 gamma up near spook it was 180 gamma and then on the other
side of the limb where you park the rover at the last station it was 120 gamma and at
that station you put a rock on it and it looks like we measured about 4.7 gamma from
that rock.
So the rock was large enough and had a large enough moment it looks like we did see a difference
and these measurements do have an airbar on them that is like plus or minus as much
now as 5 to 10 gamma because the solar wind and all the other inductive fields that are
around that have to be subtracted out of the measurements from our magnetic from the
tape and data reduction.
The measurements at station 5 were pointed upward that was it and the measurements up
near north rake crater were pointed downward at 314 gamma.
I think that there are some things that we could probably say making a lot of assumptions
but it looks like if this highland material is older than the other it looks like that
we have at least a chance of looking at the paleomagnetic history of the lunar crust
from these measurements.
The high fields indicate that either the the perming source the source of this field was
if it remains stable over the time period that tomorrow was were cooling then the highland
material would indicate this high field would indicate that it indeed had a time variation
in its magnitude or that the maria the flooding of the maria basins or whatever caused
the maria basins to be as they are today demagnetized the material that had been there originally.
It's in other words the maria material is less magnetic it seems than this material.
The interesting thing too is that the samples as you know are from the regolith and they
really physically been modified over the years and I think that the measurements that we've
obtained over over scale size near 10 kilometers indicate that we're looking at a depth
below the regolith and that this is indicative of fields that were at the moon during a
time period before in the order of three to four billion years ago the direction and the
other thing that we can say now from the from measurements of the solar wind simultaneous
measurements of solar wind and magnetic fields at the Apollo 12 and 15 site we can say that
these high fields that you measured at the Apollo 16 site modifies drastically the the
direction and interaction of the solar wind at the moon at these places it should channel the
charge particles and either at different locations asymmetrically on the lunar surface in these
areas and in some cases that what one can now state that the scale size of the field are
large enough so that you could form a shock and actually stand off the solar wind over
small region to get that covers both of them. Do you have any questions you want to ask the
crew concerning anything about the deployment or any of the experiments that you know about
Parma let me ask you what is the effect of that rock after by the big LSM did that hurt it
No first where you where you parked the rover the first time in the TV camera we were extremely
disturbed because the angle was such it looked like that rock was as big as the electronics box and
it looks like that the PRAs were oriented so it was shining right into them and all the IR
radiation would really heat us up during that A time but then the other view showed that the
rock was relatively small compared to the dimensions of the box and it didn't affect the
thermal subsystem at all and magnetically it didn't they really want to contain that
much oriented field for doing that. I guess one of the things I'd like to say is this what we
intended to do was we intended to drive a hundred yards away from the front of the lunar
module with a with a rover and doing sort of a north-south traverse looking for the best
place to deploy else up to get it away from all these things that we ran into problems with it
with a UV and that it took longer to do that last measurements and anticipated and we couldn't
do that and I'm sure that somebody looking at the photos can find a better place out in front
of the lunar module to put the total package but I like to say that package is so big and that
surface is so blocking and so full of craters then under a certain distance is almost
we had to take what we got and I hate to say that but then I just wouldn't believe that that
surface was as rough and it's covered with blocks as it turned out to be. I think I could have
still been walking up there with that package if I'd have been looking for a level spot I got
up on top of the ridge and I looked at them and said well there's a good place over there and
I ran over there and it didn't look any better in the place I just been and well there's a good
place over there and I ran over there and I only have to back to third time I said well look I'm
going to put this thing down here at best we got but it's really blocky and a lot of fresh
craters here secondary. Well I think that if you look at at least the magnetometers I looked at
each of the photos that I could find where you'd taken a picture of both the LSF magnetometer
and the portable you picked you didn't put the thing next to rocks or craters on the scale size
it was big enough to affect the instrument I think that's the main criteria which was the
observed during that. John did you know the rationale for doing that unplanned portable magnetometer
reading? Nobody doesn't make any difference I mean we did it. You can't explain it real
time. That's all right. One on a hardware the Sunshield on the LSM the latch didn't come loose
and I kept pulling the arms up to try to get that latch loose and I finally had to hold the arm
down and get the latch loose with the other hand and then as I tried to lock the thing the latch
didn't fall off it tangled up into that little wire that locks in a little ball and that was
almost left it like that without locking it and in fact Houston said go ahead and leave it but
one more to left for the thing finally dropped off and I thought I was going to disturb the level
but if you seem like you're satisfied with the level. The only thing I'm worried about there is that
we've got a level sensor in the thing and if you disturb that you can sort of see that juggle but
the the azimuth you know when you read that shadow graph off that's the only measurement we get
in azimuth ever and so as long as you could you didn't disturb the twisting of it then it's fine.
Okay thank you Paul. Next experimenter we'll be Dr. Gary Latham pass the size of the experiment.
Yes yes go ahead.
Actually actually after you've had the three footer I think was that's correct yes and we didn't
touch it after that. If there are any questions before any time after the discussion feel free
just raise your hand. Our fun began as you know with the S4B impact on this mission you also know
we lost tracking on it prematurely which which meant that we were not able to get the coordinates
and time of the impact independent of our own measurements. Nevertheless we could locate it fairly
well from the two near stations 12 and 14 which made it a useful impact at the greater range of the
station 15 and we are looking at those signals now it I think we can say that this
peculiarly high velocity mantle as we call it that we had found in the 12 and 14 region count
be a global feature unless it is exceedingly thin a thin slab of this high velocity stop the
signals we got and I must say this that there is always the uncertainty that we really didn't see
the first arrival up there because it was at 1100 kilometers and the first signal you see is quite
weak there's always the uncertainty as to whether or not it is the first the fastest traveling
wave in the moon and not something else but if it is then this very high velocity material
that we called mantle is not global or exceedingly thin layer looks as though we get velocities
approaching eight kilometers per second at the depths of the moon of the order of 100 kilometers
not nine kilometers per second as we had in the 12 and 14 region is also very weak evidence from
that signal and I haven't convinced my colleagues of this yet know myself really but
possibility of a reflection from a very deep interface perhaps 550 kilometers deep
is there and we're looking for ways to see whether or not that can be verified
in the words a primitive color perhaps or some other reflector at very great depth so this impact
we'll I think provide very very useful data despite the loss of tracking we would have been of course
much better off had been able to photograph that impact area and I understand the curtailed
time and all but concluded that we did not photograph it and that is for being you know
the deployment was good I think the pictures tell the story as far as I'm concerned the
instrument does get hot during a lunar day as the other instruments had this has been the case
in everyone I think it's a matter of just it's just not possible to keep dust off of that shroud
I think when you have to work that close to it and that that degrees the thermal control of some
it does not degrade the seismic data simply means that the controllers have more work to do
trying to maintain the thermal stability and it's a problem we faced in every one of the mission
so it's not in fact I thought the deployment to the configuration of the shroud that I saw and
so on look very very good there's one little place where it's raised up is where the cable comes out
underneath it's turned on its edge a little bit and that of course is something of a heat loss
but it's not serious at all yeah we we've had it at rascal down because of the 15 problems
but maybe it's before a guy leaves at alcep site if he's got a problem like it maybe it's
alcep on 17 probably it's not his alcep is on to the seismic at seismic and okay well
those rascaly things assumed some different kind of orientation than they did for we left
before we left and maybe you ought to go back one more time and make sure those things are
haven't changed don't ask me I think maybe they out gas a little and then take up a different shape
well it's not only it's not only your your near activities I think when we saw that that
TV picture degrade on Lemassant it's obvious a whole lot of debris is being thrown around and you
just can't avoid a good dusting down from that source so our our carefully prepared thermal
surfaces act more like black bodies than anybody figured on as a result of all of this
then we saw your rover signals which this time provided very very interesting data
in that they showed there are abrupt changes in signal level as you moved around
we're not sure yet what to make of that we're going to work with Bill Mulburger and his crew
carefully on the traverse to see whether or not we can identify specific provinces in which
the signal level is quite a bit higher I guess I would like to ask your impression as you were
rolling along and given along the given EVAs that you you felt at at given times the rover was
bouncing noticeably more than another times that might have generated higher signal levels
sometimes she was off the ground there's no doubt about that to the south
EVA2 that area was a lot rougher than the traverse route to North Ray Crater
my impression of North Ray Crater traverse once we passed Palmetto was it was
really bolder-free area very subdued old craters than the rover just sped along
much like a west Texas type terrain whereas to the south it was
really rough and particularly on survey ridge when we were traversing that area with all the
secondary some blocks we managed to be up in here quite a bit simply because there were so many
secondary and blocks that we had to hit some small ones to avoid the big ones
the subjective opinion of mine also is that around at least at stop 13 where we actually got
off the rover the regolith did not seem as is loosely compacted as to the south and in fact in
North Ray Crater at station 11 and 12 it was no more than a couple inches deep because we couldn't
get the rake in without bending the times of the rake so the regolith up there was very thin
and I don't know where that means there's a just some very cobbly thisly compacted blocks under
there from that were thrown out or that are now that much covered or whether we just pick some
bad size but we tried to rake twice and both times the only luck we had was kicking stuff into
the rake we couldn't pull the rake through the regolith and you couldn't stick the
tongs in either and the tongs wouldn't go in and every other place you could take the tongs
and stick in the ground and extend up for you you know in general this area from from the
general character of our signals it gives the appearance of being the thickest pile of what we
can quite loosely call regolith of any of the sites and I guess Bob Kovach will talk on his
results him on that and of course we await his his mortar firing to give us a little more
information on that well we'll be looking at these rover signals and see if we can we can somehow
pin them down to to roughness of terrain or just what from the pictures that you took along the way
uh we now have the the quiet nighttime period and we're waiting for the first moon quake of this
session which which ought to be well I was hoping it would be in the last 24 hours it wasn't
but should be before May 12th so in the next few days and of course with this last station we now
have completed a very nice triangular array the other three gave us a very narrow base thing now
we have a thing with a thousand kilometer baseline which which if it lasts for as long as they
appear to be lasting we'll give us the tools to really do the job over the next couple of years
and of course we'll be using that in the S4B impact from the next mission
I'd like to turn to to one observation reported from orbit that that has interested us to
great deal on that was the flash that was reported I haven't seen I understand the transcript
is now hasn't yet been tight I haven't seen it yet so I that's my only hope for pinning down
the time if you get into about five minutes with anything if you can help us pin down the time
and roughly the location we'll certainly look at our records and that would be an important piece
of data if we recorded that would like to ask was this a colored flash or a white flash white
what was your how does it differ from the kind of thing you get with a cosmic ray impact on your
brain I didn't see any of those I see well we're very much excited by that as far as I know
it's the first report of a transient event of some nature that's been seen from orbit
I just have to wait for the I should have written it down and it just didn't occur to me to
write it down we got a time on it and all that can or it's on the DSC it's on the DSC if I ever get
that all then I would correlate information we get to that size you know how about its persistence
no it was just it was just a flash and the way I hadn't noticed it I was looking at a horizon
that was showing up from solar corona or zodiacal light whatever you want to call it in that region
it was very shortly after we lost signal from earth and I was watching stars pop up over the horizon
and got this flash which was in size was about I didn't know I wouldn't look directly at it at
the time it hadn't happened down in the side of my vision but it was brighter than the
brightest star that I had in the field of view at the time and I had the feeling that it was
in physical or angular size it was equivalent to the size of the larger star and it might
receive but it was just an instantaneous flash and it took us a couple of seconds for it to soak
in to me that it wasn't just a star popping up over the horizon but rather it had been distinctly
below the horizon is there a way for me to get that transcript I don't know if I would normally
get it I'm glad I'm glad you asked oh that's it I forgot to mention this in the opening remarks
but we have about 50 copies of this technical area to ground voice transfer right back there
and for the PI's and the collies and there's a copy for you Gary back that's not what you're
going to be on there all the DSC and that hasn't been completed as far as I know okay
now one thing that I'd like to mention it from orbit that appeared to me that there was a distinctly
different unit up around North Ray and an area that a problem I'd say a third to a half of the
traverse to North Ray when across and that may or may not fit in with your size and the delta
that at some point between North Ray and the Lemley they would cross a contact at some kind yes
well it's up to add my thanks for a very fine deployment that's all I have
any questions on the floor well I don't know where the S4B hit but this is on the on the backside
of the Lem so I would assume that the S4B didn't hit there and as well after that like a couple of
days lunar days
Oh
no the the time I was doing this I was looking out the window and I had
Darken the cockpit in preparation for one of the low-light-level
photographic exercises. And that's how I happen to be noticing that there was
this distinct horizon which surprised me.
And I just happen to be kind of puzzling over that at the time.
Do you have any questions?
I'm sorry, I'll see you in the first two.
No, not when your visors down.
The front is up.
I never looked.
What do I suppose to do that?
I suspect from what we saw an EVA on the way home,
that the inner visor alone has sufficient attenuation to block out stars.
But you could see them through the AOT and the lunar module,
and of course that has a light shield around it.
On our last alignment, even with a crescent earth in the AOT,
we could see art in our real, real, really so good that we didn't have to roll up the window shades in the cockpit.
So with the proper, if you look through a tube, I'm sure you could see every star up there.
The only thing we saw in the lunar surface was the earth.
And you had to, it was directly overhead.
That was the only thing I saw in the sky.
You see your helmet reflected.
That's what you see.
You have to raise your visor and get a light.
So you can get rid of all those reflections.
Okay, next one is active seismic experiment.
Dr. Kovach.
Well, we have several objectives on this experiment.
And I'd like to summarize these basic questions like how thick is the seismic
regolith would be one question.
What were the in situ physical properties of the lunar near surface material?
And thirdly, are there any distinct seismic horizons?
And how do they correlate with our estimates to geological horizons?
And finally, were there any regional differences in seismic velocity?
Did I eat something characteristically different between the Murray and the Highlands?
Well, the deployment and the execution of the Thumper experiment was outstanding.
I mean, the records are clearer.
And the background noise was sufficiently low.
I mean, got clean first breaks completely down the geophone line.
Couldn't have answered a bit.
Sorry about that first one.
I thought really happy when that raft will work that I stopped walking.
I started walking to the next.
Well, the record shows that for some reason you inadvertently didn't hold it.
And the charge positions sufficiently long enough.
And that's the reason when you did it the second time.
No.
I thought I started walking too soon after the first one went off.
The one had failed.
Yeah, that was my pure procedure there.
Well, if you walk too soon, it didn't hurt us any.
Didn't body?
Okay.
The data needs yet to be corrected for topographic effects.
There are some severe undulations in the topography.
And we can see this in the data.
But I can give you some first impressions of our results.
Number one, there's certainly no variability in the first arrival of velocities across the geophone array.
And the parent velocity or the velocity is again very close to 100 meters per second.
Which seems to be the magic number for the regolith at many different places now on the moon.
I.e. out in the mary and now up here in the final up in this highland site.
There are no evidence of flows beneath the beneath this geophone line.
I feel sufficiently confident we would have recognized that.
Now, the fact that we didn't recognize any variability in the velocity,
we're able to say one more thing because we'd be part of the limb ascent when we turn on the geophone line.
And that's position in some hundred and forty meters away from our first geophone.
And we did get a faster apparent velocity.
And it's very close to the value measured for Phromaro for Bretchius.
And so with this type of a number now, I eat two to three hundred meters per second underlying this regolith.
We can put a thickness bound on the regolith at this site.
And it is indeed very thick, at least forty meters.
And I'll be able to refine that number a little bit when we get the mortars fired.
We also did turn on the ASE geophone array and recorded your rover approaching the limb during the NDA3.
And we also got very interesting signals.
And we hope to analyze these in an analogous way as Gary has suggested.
And that's about all I can say.
For the quick look of our data at this point, we do have the concern of course.
I do have the concern about the grenade box deployment.
I'm sure I've asked you that.
I haven't seen any of the pictures yet, so maybe the self-explained.
Maybe you could reassure me that it's level.
It's level.
I guarantee.
As active, that was probably the only level place we had around there.
And I was really pleased to see when we got out the end of the...
to where we could deploy it, that would be level.
It's really good.
And I reported the...
I don't remember what asthma is heading that we put it on.
It was very close.
It seemed like it was three, three, zero.
I was opposed to three, three, three that it should have been on.
That's off the top of my head.
We had to go back and look, but I reported it.
And I found out later that you could break that pin by pulling on the leg.
But I certainly didn't know that.
If somebody told me that doing the training while going right over my head.
But we do have three good legs in there.
And I'll bet you that rascal can't get out of the ground because of the weight.
And it's sort of like pushing it into quicksand.
And once it gets in there, I define anybody to get that motor box back out of there.
Because it really grabbed a hole of it.
Well, again, I'd like to offer my thanks for outstanding execution of the experiment.
You didn't ask anything good.
Thank you.
This is our pleasure.
Boy, it really worked good.
I was really pleased.
Any questions from the board?
How do you define it?
I'm excited.
What's that?
Did you see some trees?
Well, we defined the river.
I don't know how the geologist made me know the river,
but we defined the we defined the material which apparently covered as much of the lunar surface.
It has its characteristic velocity of 100 meters per second.
And what kind of happened that underneath this particular site?
I have something that has velocities like from our spreadsheet.
You said something about you were sure that there was no flow material underneath this.
I guess I missed the conclusion.
Well, we've done enough experiments on Earth.
And I say that we've been able to recognize flows because of velocities are characteristically much higher.
And if you want to argue that there may be very thin flows, i.e., thinner than our sampling wave length,
which is like two to three meters, they could be there.
But we certainly, on the average, did you see any big sequence of high velocity flows?
And we would agree.
When you say have velocity, this two or three hundred that you're talking about from the essence stage,
that's not high.
And it's every small crater that we looked into with exception, probably a buster crater.
We never saw anything that looked like anything, but I mean, it just looked like more of the same.
It looked like regolith.
I mean, you know, we never saw anything that looked like outcropper.
And we were sure looking forward.
This two is 300 meters velocity.
I'm about, well, that was the stretch of material that you say is underlined the regolith.
Is that right?
That's fine.
First look.
Oh, that's another good question.
What's the latest word on water spiraling?
Do we have any idea of what?
I don't remember now.
Well, it's me and my clock is back.
No, I'm going to request to fire it on May 23rd.
That's steel days.
And it's arm too.
Okay, our next message is a solar wind composition, Dr. Meister.
Unfortunately, there is not much to tell about the solar wind composition experiment.
The foil was transferred to Switzerland at the end of last weekend.
We don't have any results yet, of course.
The foil was deployed during the first EVA and retrieved at the end of the third EVA
with a total exposure time of 45 hours and five minutes.
That's some three hours longer than the record of the previous missions.
It was about 52 hours on Apollo 15.
The main difference between the foil of Apollo 16 and the ones of the previous missions
is that some pieces of platinum foil have been attached to the previous design,
which was composed of a pure aluminum foil.
This platinum foil piece can be cleaned by a floridic acid,
which allows to remove all the possible lunar dust contamination.
This technique has been tested in the lab on bombarded foils
and showed that you can remove essentially all the lunar dust contamination
without losing any measurable amount of trapped rare gas ions,
or atoms of solar wind origin.
This technique should allow us to determine the isotopic composition of the rare gas elements of solar wind origin
up to the mass of possibly Krypton.
A first visual inspection of the foil here at MSC showed that the foil is crimpled,
but essentially three of lunar dust.
That's of course only a visual observation.
We don't know how the foil looks like under microscope.
I would like to thank the crew for the proper deployment and retrieval of the foil.
We are very pleased with what the foil looks like.
Thank you very much.
I can't miss when I tell you where the sun is.
Yeah, point this at sun.
The thing didn't roll up like I thought it was going to,
and I'm sorry I had to crinkle it, but it was so big,
and I had to squeeze it down and get it into the bag,
and it ripped once too, I guess you saw that.
That's only a problem of aesthetics.
It doesn't hurt it.
Okay, good. I didn't spank it there.
God.
We don't believe that we have a discrimination between the lighter and heavier elements
in the solar wind.
There's a check that may be that there's a dependence on the height over the lunar surface
of the composition between the heavier and lighter elements,
but you have to check that first and see.
Is that all the lighter particles?
It's also pretty flexed, much more than the heavier ones.
Can you see those, I don't know how I can just probably stupid question,
because these particles that cause the light flashes,
I was seeing them on the lunar surface during the sleep periods.
Yeah, those things register on your experiment?
No, they have higher energies, and they go through the foil.
That's it.
Yeah.
Huh?
Well, while we close our thinking,
well, can you tell any difference in the materials
between the times of 20 times of both the factors and the illness?
No.
No difference there.
Looking at it one time out the wind,
I thought I saw some white streaks on it,
but it might have been just the way the sun was.
There might have been those platinum strips
that I'd never noticed when I'd been placed it.
I really don't know.
It just looked like I had a couple of randomly oriented streaks on it to me
from the wind, limb, window,
but when we rolled it back up again,
instead of rolling straight up, it rolled out in a big long thing,
and I had to redo it again, and when that happened,
I'd ripped it and then had to crunch it down.
We don't see any difference between the foil we sent up
and the foil that came down, except some loony dust on it.
Nothing else.
Can I ask the crew a question?
Do you have an idea how the foil was oriented?
Was it the central or vertical to the photograph?
Mine mean along the gravitational force lines,
or was it the recline or incline?
It's hard to tell it from anything.
I think I put it in almost a parallel gravity vector.
It's on a slope, a little slope, but if I recall,
it's a line almost vertically.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
The next subject would be the cosmic-ready detector,
Dr. Bob Fleischer.
See you here.
Oh, okay.
The PIs could be here this morning.
They're busy at home studying the data that they got back.
I have some words from them that I'll pass along as to what they think they'll be able to see.
They are very excited about the possibilities they have.
Early in the mission, there was a solar particle event that occurred,
which will enhance their data very significantly.
They think they'll have the opportunity to see particles from the sun on an ordinary mission.
They would have never had the opportunity to see.
When they got the experiment back, panel one did have considerable dust on it.
This, from the best we can tell without any analysis,
from the landing itself, from the blast up from the DPS,
panel one was hot in the taking the panels apart.
Panel two and three were cooler, and panel four was of the same order of temperatures as panel two and three.
The cosmic ray data itself in the plastics appears to be degraded somewhat because of the temperature,
but they're very hopeful that a great part of the data will be retrievable.
At the first look on panel two, Dr. Fleischer says that the number of particles they see on the plastics,
indeed, are a great deal higher than they would have normally anticipated,
indicating the effects of the solar particle event.
And they really haven't, in detail, etched the plastics or analyzed,
and they're just beginning to do that.
They think they are usable.
Yes, the plastics.
I'm really surprised because we had some lengthy discussions about this preflight,
and I can never understand how we're going to fly this rascal to the moon
and get it there with these long periods of attitude hole that we're going into,
where it might see plus 250 all the time.
And of course, I'm sure those three revs and lunar orbit prior to landing didn't do any good,
either because we were oriented many times so that we were facing with the maintained communications.
We had the sun shining on that rascal all the way around.
And I really think that those 140 temperatures that we saw in the panels,
if you go back and look at it thermally, you're going to find out there where they had to be there long before we ever got the thing on the ground.
And I was really concerned about that as to why we didn't put some kind of shielding over it.
But it was too late, I guess, to do this.
Well, the thermal design was such that it could sit, I believe, in direct sunlight,
and most indefinitely without any degradation in star heating off the lunar surface that really cooks it from.
That's what the thermal people say.
I think, and it's hard to say, and we did see that the early picture did show that the temple labels had already changed early at the beginning of the EVA.
They were black first time when they were down.
And I guess is the 15 hours, the thermal analysis says if there's like 15% dust on the panel after 20 degrees of sun angle or so you will sort of exceed the 140 degrees on the frame.
It appeared that there was probably 50 or 60% dust on the lower part of the panel, or maybe even higher than that.
And it spent about 15 hours on the surface.
So it may have just turned out to be a number of problems that probably ones that could not be avoided under the circumstances that caused that lower panel over heat.
It was the hottest.
And the next panel was about 20 degrees cooler.
The best we can tell in the panel.
The third panel up was 10 degrees cooler than the second panel.
So it seemed to be a dust problem, but it doesn't seem to have hurt the date of too much.
Panel 4 was the one which was, we were afraid, wasn't going to be activated because of the anomaly on the red lanyard.
But after they have taken the panel apart, apparently every portion of the experiment was activated to some degree or another.
The neutron portion was partially deployed and they think they will get some data from it.
It's not as much state as statistically as they wish they had.
But every portion of panel 4 does look like it will provide some useful data.
And they have a lot of higher hopes now than they did when they first saw the gear.
Apparently the problem, and we haven't sent the hardware back to the manufacturer for analysis, but apparently was a malfunction in the assembly.
And caused that thing to jam.
Well, we could have pulled, if I had known about it at the time, we could have got that pair of pliers out there and pulled harder.
The investigators opinion was it would have done well good.
It wouldn't have been very severely jammed.
It doesn't think any additional effort would have freed it.
It was jam pretty badly.
But I think in all they're very excited about the data and I think they're very optimistic now that they'll get a considerable amount of data from it.
Jim, it's probably worth mentioning on the last of panel 4.
You typically have calibrated pliers in there and they'll be able to put the effect of the already just to reveal what the factory is for the practices.
But with the calibration and the other thing is on panel 4, it's supposed to experiment with your activate by pulling the corridor on the small fraction of a total part of the panel 4.
There's a lot of panel 4.
That's true.
They've still got a lot of good data.
Okay, I don't think we, in fact, I'm sure you may find a fingerprint on there, but if there is, we really are careful to get it out of there.
And once we got it loose, we have to use your 10-11 care and fold it up so I don't think there's any crew fingerprints on the panel surfaces.
That's correct. We looked at it very carefully and it was except for the bottom part of panel 1 that you could see.
It was a spray pattern. It was very clean. And the PIs were very pleased about that.
The solar part of the area was really great.
Yes, it started on about, I believe, Monday, which was the day after launch and went through about Wednesday.
It's about a two or three-day type of event. I think the peak was, must have been about Tuesday.
There are some satellite data available, I don't have it on hand.
It was a small event, but for this solar cycle it was very surprising that it happened at all during the mission that to have it during the portion when the cosmic ray was deployed or available to accept that it was,
the probably that's very small, so it's a very gratifying thing to occur.
I'm sure it's sent out in a thin layer.
Those frontal blocks around there, it's a possibility some of it could come back at you, that's for sure.
It was extremely hard to see. And when we photographed it, the lights are not similar to the sun, probably much less in intensity,
but yet the photographic lights did wash out. It's a very pale kind of dust, but it's very predominant.
And it came up from the corner day even in a pattern that you would expect it to be blown in.
Some black streaks in there that are prepared to be melted something or other on it.
And I think they are going to attempt to chemically analyze the material and try to find out what it is.
I don't know about the first panel must be about chest high, is it not?
Yeah. Any other questions?
Just one comment, the frame of that thing was hot, really it was hot.
That was the only thing I felt through my gloves, the whole state.
It was jamming, John tried to pull it out and I was holding the frame and I started feeling it through my gloves.
Did you just get an email for why I was jamming your work?
It was jamming at the base, right at the bottom part.
It was something that broke free right at the base and then it just came out like head grease on.
Maybe we spill some orange juice over.
No way.
That's the only thing we didn't spill orange juice on.
It's not that you didn't try it.
It's a good cement you guys, you ought to start thinking about that.
That's the vacuum morn.
Okay, our next experiment was the far UV camera duct page.
Just here all the golds, purposes of this experiment, which were to obtain photographs,
of the geocoroner, the upper atmosphere of the earth.
I should have said these photographs of course include spectra as well.
Solar wind clouds possibly, either stellar hydrogen colors of stars in the far ultraviolet
and possibly intergalactic hydrogen.
We had a lot of troubles, I guess John well knows.
Before launch, the difficulty was to keep the camera dry because it's optically sensitive
surface would immediately run away if it got damp.
This was accomplished with a bag that caused that to me on a little bit of trouble
and practices and advance, but apparently worked all right on our surface.
It's great.
The second difficulty was getting through the Van Allen belts without fogging our film
and I'll show you in a moment that we did that all right with rather small amount of shielding around the film cassette.
Then we had some difficulty with the landing in the way.
This came about because of the delay and touched down high sun angle and then the necessity
to keep the camera close to the land so that it would be in the shadow.
With its gold surface, it would have heated up very rapidly.
It had been out in the full summer.
The accomplishments that I will show you in a moment on the screen include 92 photographs
in the Lyman Alpha imagery and 53 specter, some of them extending from 500 angstroms to 1550 angstroms.
I think the farthest into the ultraviolet anybody's ever taken astronomical pictures.
We may get evidence of gases in the lunar atmosphere from several of our pointings which were low across the lunar horizon.
If anything, we're coming out like the geysers of water or whatever it is.
We'll certainly pick it up.
The data on these photographs are extremely numerous and it'll take us an estimated six months to a year
to get them all out which will be done with the big computer here at the MSC.
So Dr. George Carruthers, who was the PI and the design of the camera,
had to be free today from work on an Arab-y flight and it's here.
We'll undoubtedly make comments whenever he sees something to comment on the photographs.
We have the first slide.
I might say that I got into trouble with an American photographer's union
in thanking the prints of these because I'm not a member of that unit
and they tried to throw me out of the darker color here.
This is probably one of the most dramatic pictures of the years that shows a rural belt on the dark side.
You're looking at the years with the sun off to your right.
The south pole of the earth is down and that funny lip-like thing sticking off to the left of the bottom
is Aurora, we think, around the south magnetic pole.
The most striking thing is the next lip up which, on the original,
you can see better than on this slide, goes around the full back side of the earth.
It's called the equatorial auroral belt.
And this appears back of the dark side in the upper left corner.
The third lip is another belt.
It looks at first as if that was just all one, but there are two separate belts there.
And it was quite unexpected.
This photo was the continuation of the area of the statue size.
Well, you know, it's 8,000 miles across it.
You're a...
There's some relation here.
And I guess I'm not too sure in perhaps George knows them.
This is a special Eastman MTB-3 emulsion, very, very thin.
And, of course, the exposure was made with electrons, not with light.
It's an electronic graphic camera.
But the dimension works outright.
You can't see it too well on this print.
There's a ring or a limit to the field which, on the originals, is 30 millimeters across.
It's 20 degrees in the sky, and the earth is 2 degrees, and it checks out.
So, the dimension you see there is 2 degrees across the full diameter of the area.
You say it's just the equatorial auroral belt.
I think what I'm trying to say is that once that the third light from the bottom,
is that the back side of your ceiling?
No, you can't see it through the earth.
That's why I asked you, because it was the top of the bottom.
But the geometry is such that that is probably inclined 30 degrees to the magnetic equator,
and is an unexpected auroral belt.
It'll take a little more figuring to figure this out.
But, as I just said, my guess, looking at the picture, hasn't been measured accurately, is 30 degrees north.
You'll notice on these pictures that they're over-printed.
That's because I'm not a member of the photographers unit.
And the originals have a good deal more on them.
This picture was taken excluding hydrogen light, limon alpha.
We have two filters on the camera, and this one is taken in light between the wavelengths of 12.
30, and 15, and 50 angstroms.
Now, the next slide, yeah?
Is that old I ever seen there?
Is that old the earth close?
That twice one here?
No, it's the earth, just the earth.
The old thing is the earth, right?
No, that twice the image.
No, no.
As I said, the little halation, which makes it a little bigger than it ought to be.
The earth is in the middle there, and if you look real hard, you can see the dark side of it off to your left.
This is the geocorona.
The streaks are an instrumental matter.
Actually, we have a barrier membrane that George put very close in front of the film to keep visible light
from getting in there, and the barrier membrane wasn't quite uniform, and that's where the streaks come from.
The circular thing on the right is an overlap, another defect,
a little motor that danced the film between exposures.
Didn't pull it quite far enough for this one, and those dust specks, I guess, might pipe the back on the slide.
That rastly thing was moving.
At first, it wasn't moving.
The wheels weren't going as far as they did.
Now, we have a complete transcript of everything you said about it, and looking at the film, which I've done in great detail,
you can see the most serious defect in that film advance was during your short exposures on the earth, John.
It worked fine.
And I have an idea that pushing the buttons so frequently sort of confused the motor, and it didn't turn as far as it should have.
Well, in any case, you'll notice that the shape of the geocorona is predicted by Dr. Meyer at the Naval Research Lab.
It's got a dimple in the back, down sun.
The sun is still to the right here.
And our other photographs show that it extends at least twice as far as you see here off to the right.
The print, of course, can be printed dark or light, and if I printed this one lighter, I'd have got the background all over the hole slide,
and you wouldn't have been able to see as pretty a picture as this.
Now, the next slide shows the one further to the right.
The sun is still to your right.
The earth's now is off the edge of the picture to the left.
This was one of the sequence taken through the night between EVAs 2 and 3.
You see a star background here.
And again, the geocorona, those streaks, which are not real, extending actually right across this frame if you print the thing lighter.
Now, the next slide shows the two of these combined, and that printed a lot darker.
And I guess it's not as artistic enough or as I had hoped.
The geocorona produces is hydrogen, in 12, 16 engines line of alpha.
And the next slide shows the spectrum actually taken on that first slide.
The spectrum is dispersion, is vertical, and that white band across horizontally is line of alpha.
You see how strong it is.
The earth is in the middle of this picture, and the spectrum of the upper atmosphere is spread out on that vertical line.
From far ultraviolet down at the bottom to near ultraviolet at the top.
The bright line, just above line of alpha, is 1304, which is oxygen line.
And George, do you want to describe this one more detail?
We've so far only made a very crude analysis of the spectrum.
By comparison, the laboratory spectrum made in the pre-flight calibrations.
However, we have tentatively identified the 584 line of helium, the 834 line of ionized oxygen.
The 1026 line and beta of hydrogen, these three lines are the first spectral measurements in the earth's upper atmosphere.
All previous measurements have been limited to wavelengths longward of the 1100 angstroms.
Which we also cover, and which includes the line of alpha line in 1216.
The 1304 and 1356 lines of atomic oxygen.
And the Lyman-Hertberg-Hopfield bands of molecular nitrogen between 1200 and 1600 angstroms.
The Lyman-Hopfield line, of course, is by far the strongest emission that we have seen in any of our spectra.
And it's the only one that we have conclusively identified in any of the spectra that do not include the earth.
However, by comparison of spectra taken with and without our lithium chloride corrector plate, which cuts off at 1050 angstroms,
we will be able to determine whether we see a general background in the 584 line of helium and the 1026 line of oxygen.
And so we expect, though, there will be much weaker than the Lyman-Hopfield line.
We've got that other spectrum coming.
In other words, can you hold on a minute?
I think the order he's got on me and has the Magellanic cloud in it.
And we're probably taking too much time.
We have the next slide.
Well, that's it, going into it.
So this is without the corrector plate.
You notice that the Lyman-Hopfield here is broader.
The definition is poorer, but as George is just saying, we get the lines further down in the ultraviolet,
on spectra taken without the corrector plate with it.
And you see here, too, these other lines are not uniform.
This is a spectrum that was obtained with the earth off the edge here.
So it shows that the geocuronic was right across this slide, as I said last time.
By the way, that's 100,000 miles.
And the other lines here show that either other materials in the geocuronic or beyond the geocuronic,
I guess it's going to take a little while to figure out which or which.
Go ahead.
Let's get on.
I get more.
The next two slides quickly show that, well, that's why it's one.
The Magellanic Clouds, which are, well, John was worried about what the Lyman is seeing.
And this is the large Lyman-Hopfield.
And that's the initial referred to.
The picture on the left is with hydrogen, with Lyman-Hopfield.
And the picture on the right is without it.
In this far, Colorado region, all the genes are seen here are the very hot blue stars.
And over here, you see the clouds of hydrogen gas.
So the difference between these two photographs is hydrogen.
And we get the right picture of the Magellanic Clouds are nearby galaxies.
So we have a galaxy with all the stars.
And then we're going to spread out in front of this to study.
Carl Hennice, the three special studies of these Magellanic Clouds.
And this very much interested in already has copies of these photographs.
But you notice that hydrogen is not just from the Magellanic Clouds.
The stuff up here is of the open sky and just what caused that background.
I don't know.
Is there any other slide?
That's the last one.
We had a couple of studies for John.
One was that sticking, which had us worried.
You talked about the instrument.
They fly on to all 17 records.
Very interested in it.
And so what was the sticking?
Did it continue right through?
You didn't mention it in the A-3.
It got worse all along.
I just got the feeling there was some kind of hang-up between,
possibly long-term vacuum exposure or something to the operation of the way it was working in asthma.
And I never was able to never able to do it.
No, it never got better.
In fact, this is the longer it sat there.
Maybe the cold.
It just seemed to get stickier and stickier.
Toward in there, every time I had to, every time I got to a new setting in asthma,
they completely destroy the level.
And we're unfortunate that we were on that slope right there.
It's under the foot pad of the limb.
So I had to go back and re-level it every time.
And that was, we were really working at the limits of the level,
the level ability of the machinery, I think, there.
You see it didn't make much difference.
Did that match on the cloud should have been out in the middle?
I know.
You were off by that much, because.
But if we were on a level slope, there would have been no problem
with bubble right in the middle every time.
And if they asked me if it worked easily, it would have remained level right.
But I sure don't know what it was.
You couldn't have been does it got in there?
No, I don't think that was impossible.
No, I don't think we had any, in fact, I'm sure we didn't have any dust on the legs up that far.
The film just said you brought back and buried on the dust on it.
In fact, it looked pretty new.
Well, if it got, if it got dust on it, it got it inside the limb.
There was plenty in there once we got in the zero gravity.
Although I don't know how to crawl through two bags.
That's why I was quite surprised that it was no dust, but we're disappointed
because we're going to collect a little bit of dust off of them.
Any questions from the board?
And I'm sure it got some dust on it when I removed it, though.
Well, I got a little bit of a very small amount, which I'm still able to keep thinking about this.
Don't tell anybody the FBI will be around to see.
Did you see evidence?
I think I can actually do it all the time.
So far we have not seen any discontinuity in the up-subgeo-grown,
which would be over the kidney cleaner in fact.
It just sort of triples off.
But wait, thank you both.
Somewhere from the earth in there.
It's no sharp drop.
But we're really not as far as the bone shock from it.
Can't really react.
I should have been in the middle of that.
I guess this is only 10.
12.
OK, more questions.
OK.
Next subject is the linear geology investigation.
Back to Boulder.
For the benefit of the astrologer in the crowd,
there have been very little evidence for water,
and none so far for geysers.
Our experiment may not be as far reaching as there.
But on the other hand, I think we've made a large step toward
understanding the history of the moon,
and therefore the earth and therefore the solar system.
And if you guys can find any more, we're out there with you.
So far we've completed the mission itself
and all major objectives for the pre-planned traverses
were reached, and we're sampled, and we're described
and photographed.
And as far as we can tell, with our quick look at the photographs,
all of these were done well.
We've produced a so-called green back at the end of the mission
operations itself, which was a summary as ever.
Knowledge at that time is based on crew observations,
TV, and the pre-mission data.
Included in that thing are station sample maps,
which are derived from the TV in real time.
And that was a very useful tool to us.
A sample inventory, a film usage inventory,
and a station locations, again,
resected from the TV pans.
By the end of last week, we could receive black and white two time
enlargements of all film.
These are the typical drugstore quality prints.
And sooner or later, we'll get good quality,
so our analysis was very brief.
We've assembled all the panoramas.
Sample location studies are nearing completion.
The film inventory is also nearing completion.
The geological analysis is still in its infancy,
and I suspect should progress rapidly now that we've got all
this inventorying over with.
The guys takes a damn many pictures and takes time to get them organized.
We've had one session with a crew in the LRL with samples,
and most of our questions need samples in hand.
And those will, I'm sure we'll be able to discuss later.
And so the questions I've gone relate more to surface observations
that maybe we can amplify.
And some of these are questions that we've asked you before,
but I have a few Polaroid prints of these photos
that maybe can jostle our minds.
And assistant refining some of the answers
that we've gotten on the debriefs after the EVAs
or on transfer.
Our photo geologic mapping group primarily talked about
rays by their whiteness.
There were few spots where they thought they were seeing dark rays.
You recognize both light and dark colored rays,
particularly the south ray picture.
If I could have a slide, one please,
which is the south ray panorama,
and the print I've just given to the crew a single frame from that.
There I think we can see light and dark.
And the real question I'm after is what led you to say
that you were on or off a ray?
And secondly, are there any visible differences
in the rock types as you drove by
or had a chance of sampling ray material?
Yeah.
Sure looks that way.
The hills are at the bottom.
Yeah, I think the thumb grid goes near but right.
The projection is to give that a 180 please,
around a horizontal axis.
That one's got the same problem.
There we go.
Now it's a hill instead of a hole.
This is your pan from station four.
Yeah, you see that black line coming over the,
this photo really doesn't do that.
No justice.
Polaroid prints never do.
Well, I mean, I really have to see it to believe it.
That white is so much wider than the contrast
that we're able to get out of the photographs.
I think when I looked at it,
my assessment of this, which is kind of bad place,
was that it was a black ray coming out.
The right one there on the photograph.
And it probably went right down that to,
because you know that the photograph that showed the black area
coming out of South Ray.
Right there.
And there's a series of black, black blocks.
There's a bunch right there.
Left edge.
And there's also Charlie described this in real time.
There's some more black blocks in there.
And they seem to come out and write patterns too.
And she thinks, Charlie, that's one spectacular crater.
That ray coming down to South,
South right edge might have been the ray that made,
or at least part of it, that made Survey Ridge.
Because it just ran right across those rec trap craters
and we could see it going all the way down.
Is that the bright ray you're talking about in the lower right?
This ray right here, Bill, came right through study,
right up over and right out Survey Ridge.
So that was the source of your terrific block field there.
Man, just amazing how much rocks have rascal weighed down.
I just couldn't believe it.
I tried to build the end close to that thing.
It would probably have been very interesting.
We should have had another EVA to find out.
I think so.
He flew one.
The reason we called we were on a ray was really a bonus of secondary craters
and an abundance of blocks.
And the thinned and thickened as we, I think,
traverse raised, raised, but we never did get
completely out of blocks to the south,
to the traverse to the south.
It was always three to five percent of the surface had cobbles.
And I say cobbles a 20 centimeter blocks and larger.
And the blocks were generally asymmetrical enough to the crater
or the crater shape was elongated or just the greater spattering of craters
as while you're calling them secondary.
I think subjectically we felt they were oriented from South Ray all the time.
There was really just a subjective field as we were driving by them.
There were a lot of the blocks that were not associated with any craters.
There would be a pile of a series of secondaries,
but around for a couple hundred meters,
there'd be more blocks.
In fact, as far as you could see,
there'd be blocks just scattered over the surface
that were not associated with any secondaries.
But the true secondaries were,
we did see some that were classic,
where you could be ejected,
was downrange from an appointed right to South Ray.
Station four, for instance, was one that was...
Can I have slide four, please?
I might add that these black rays
and the black blocks that you see here were also evident at Baby Ray.
Can you rotate that one too?
And to a lesser degree,
the sampling at North Ray had an appearance of being black
and white matrixed black and white rocks.
The North Ray rocks.
Do these black streaks go all into the crater themselves
down vertically down into the size of the crater?
It's South Ray, yeah.
That one on the left that you saw there
was you could track it over the rim
and back right across the rim.
And can you see that from orbit?
You can see a lot of these fresh black-street craters.
This one...
South Ray does not have nearly the obvious dark streaks
that run down inside and outside that many of the other craters do.
There was dark material, dark appearing material,
it was very obvious in the crater interior,
but I never recognized it as being a ray that was thrown out
with a radial dimension.
Yeah, I think looking at the photography,
the feeling we got from looking at South Ray
was that that black streak was just an absence of any rays,
I think it's from the blocks that must be black ray material.
Dark material.
Maybe the dark matrix rocks would produce that darkening.
It petered out a lot faster than the white rays of,
you know, within a quarter of a crater down the bottom of the bottom.
From the bottom of it.
Those could disappear just because of their general appearance.
Like the local regolith,
the white ones being so obviously different.
It'd be easy to recognize.
I suspect why the mappers did the same thing.
Here's your pan, John, from...
or part of it looking up sun.
And this crater you suggested was the secondary.
And therefore the sampling that you were doing primarily over there
to the left corners where the rover is.
There would be South Ray, Jack, as the principal source.
There's one reason we wanted to move you on,
and I think I was a good decision now that we look at your photographs
and from what you told us.
Well, we sample this crater up on this close-in rim
and down the rim a little bit, but I...
Man, that's another classic secondary.
I never saw one.
That's type locality if you're part of the geological bridge.
And you can see the debris from there,
just scattered all out in here too.
The rover's back over here.
Downslope.
You can see it right in the left corner, just the edge of it.
Oh, yeah.
And I think you're standing there, Charlie.
Probably on my face.
Okay.
Here, the related to this are some of the craters
that you called intorated and had claws around them.
Got a photo of seven, please.
And that'll probably need a 182.
Okay.
No, number seven.
Oh, yeah.
That's plumb, okay.
Now, that plumb's got a little bench in it.
And on the permission work,
there were quite a lot of them that had benches
and suggested that there was an underrated layer
that would shallow compared to what the crater counts
said that the edge of that whole surface had to be.
We just heard Covatch tell us it was a very thick regolith here,
which is what it should have had by the cratering stories.
And yet, there was always this little bench.
We're wondering now whether that bench has some relationship
to the ejecta from the South Ray and North Ray craters.
And therefore, it might be,
what you've brought up here on the rim of plumb
and some of the pre-ray, underrated regolith.
Do you have any thoughts that could go into that?
That wasn't what I was calling the indorated regolith, Phil.
Wouldn't it?
No.
That's not it.
The indorated regolith I was talking about was two meter size craters.
Yeah, two meter size.
And there were little teeny quads,
no bigger than a grapefruit.
And that were symmetrically around a very shallow crater
that had a hackley black blast right in the center
of these little craters.
And the biggest one was no more than two meters.
You see down in there?
Clumb, see those that outline of rocks down in there?
Don't know.
Keep going down right here.
Right here?
Over here.
You want to see those rocks right in there?
Well, I think,
near the bottom of the view.
I wouldn't be surprised, but what the most likely candidate
for a rock that was from down either in the bottom of plumb
or from the lower part of flag was that rock that we chipped off of.
It's located right in the center.
And I, because that had been,
that was well under the, I mean it was a submerged rock
and I got the feeling that it was sort of local to the area.
I mean, I don't see how it could have been from South Ray
or unless that was extremely soft when it plunked in there.
I didn't rule out that, but I mean, that would be the most likely candidate
of the ones we could get to.
We could, no way we could have got down in there and got those rocks.
That's true.
You've gotten back.
This is, took your tether away from you.
I don't imagine you want to explore those craters.
Okay, the buster crater of photo eight, please.
This is your partial pan of buster.
Again, not a winner for photographic work.
It's at least as good as the astrologer's pictures though.
I, you described that there was a southwest of Northeast Boulder field in here.
We're looking almost down the sun.
I'm wondering, I can't tell on these photographs.
I can't tell whether they're blocks over in there and, therefore,
your oppression of this streak.
Well, across it could not be salted by because you're looking down sun.
Well, I might have been.
I didn't really mean to say southeast northwest.
This, the predominance of blocks in buster were oriented in this direction across
that this way, which is Northeast Southwest.
That's what you said.
You're reconfirming that.
Reconfirming that in over in this area, you can see some of the blocks,
but not nearly as many as here.
We can barely see the bottom of buster, but the bottom of buster is covered
with blocks that were up to two meters across,
and showed no orientation in any direction.
My feeling over here, due to the, there were blocks in this area,
but there were not as numerous as this pattern in here.
So the blocks that you're on the side, you were standing,
would have been derived primarily from that hole,
and not from the impacting material.
It has a appearance of a secondary from South Ray in this kind of a photograph.
Your description of you do not go with that interpretation.
Well, if it is, it's the biggest one that we saw.
That is a big crater from here to here.
It was at least 50 meters.
At least, yeah.
And the size of those blocks and the depth of that crater,
and South Ray is six kilometers away.
That had to be one big block it pounded into there.
And I don't know whether you can even excavate something at large.
That's too large to be.
I don't really think it's a secondary.
So I was feeling that looking at it, it was a primary,
because I couldn't conceive of how you'd get one from.
Of course it could have maybe been a secondary from one of those big craters
way down South.
I think that's a possible thing.
So that's either local bedrock or some of the flaps,
or the thrown out material from spook that we're seeing there
in the floor in the walls.
Great.
Let's get up like that at all.
This was a lot fresher crater.
I think so.
We're searching for this business, man,
because it don't tell where that rascal came from.
OK.
I'd like to have a slide nine, please.
This is North Ray Crater.
And there were arguments among you guys in your arguments,
among ours, as to whether we're seeing layering in there.
And I think the layering that you were talking about,
John, is over in the right part where there's a dominance of blocks.
Is that a tree statement?
Right there.
That's certainly one of the best candidates for it.
Yeah.
It's just hard to imagine how the blocks would either all slump down there
and end up at that spot or slump down there and end up there.
You know, in our geology trips,
we ran across a lot of contacts.
It was a great deal more subtle than that one right there.
That's why I picked it.
There's a better view of that if you get on further to the north,
I think it shows it a little bit deeper down.
But there's certainly, if there is any...
The right polar metric hanging,
I should have had rather than a left.
Okay.
It was in use when I needed to make the picture.
You know, up at going up Stone Mountain,
there was one other crater that we were looking into
as we were driving up Stone Mountain, where we could see what looked
to be more like an aircraft than anything I've seen so far.
And it was the same kind of thing.
It wasn't broken up like that.
It was just one solid piece.
I don't think there was any way we'd gotten up the hill to it.
And we've got some photographs of that.
And it shows up on a 16 millimeter photography as we were driving up there.
And I could point it out to you, but it was about...
That, you know, one third of the way down from the top to the floor,
the same kind of...
Rover.
But that's the only two places where I'd really call out why
it would hazard a guess that that was out.
That was outcro.
Off to the left there, you can see a vertical string of blocks
right in the middle.
Far wall, yeah.
And were there any visual observations you made of that?
Well, again, I got the impression we had areas,
quite areas, and dark areas.
And maybe the dark ending was just because of the shadows caused by the rocks.
And I got the feeling those were the dark blocks like House Rock.
And then just like Charlie does.
And I got the feeling there were places where there were strings of white blocks too.
These rocks right here that are more buried are...
And the regolith is deeper in this area, is our white matrix rocks.
Around this way, and really right out from this little block here,
is House Rock sits here, and that is predominantly a black matrix rock.
And I counted nine radial block trails out of that crater.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
And there's a couple over in here.
It gave you the impression that you can track them from the floor all the way out over the rim,
at least as far as we could see.
The stake zones of blocks.
Good.
As a rascal, the actual craters don't really exhibit the classic overturn flap that we've been looking at.
They are more complicated than that when they all get shuffling around on themselves.
In here, as I said, we had impression that the regolith was more loosely consolidated
because of a footprint impression I had down at South Ray,
down at House Rock.
We already commented that we couldn't even get those tones of the shovel or the scoop in.
And around the rover, which was sitting right back out here,
it had the same problem.
And you don't get the impression from here,
but the slope going down to that block where we'd have to go down to to get a picture of the bottom of the crater
was not the kind of thing I'd want Charlie to be doing without having that 100 foot line on us,
so we didn't get any pictures of the bottom of it.
We'll wait until we get the pan camera stuff,
but look into the bottom, I guess.
No.
Or Ken's words on it.
If you can see going down there, but I'd like to be able to get him back.
Yes.
Me too.
As you can see, as you can see here, the white matrix rocks had more filleted
and it appeared to be more covered with regular than the larger rocks around it.
Over here to the north where the black matrix rocks, the house rock was.
It had some filleting, but it was not nearly so pronounced as this area to the south.
Would the House Rock TV pan do you have any things you'd want to point at?
I've got that up there in the slide if you want to.
It's lousy, but it's...
I don't think so.
I think it's a big one.
I guess it's a quarter of the way down to the bottom.
What's really hard to tell, you know that rascal is half a mile across.
So some of those rocks sitting in here must be almost as big as House Rock.
It's really hard to see.
We didn't ever see the bottom.
It's about a quarter of the way down from where we could see.
I would imagine at the bottom of North Ray looks very much like Buster,
the bottom of Buster with bigger blocks.
Hopefully the pan camera will show that, but we never...
Free mission photography.
You didn't want to get closer to that beauty.
Right in this area.
There was a bench down in here that you could probably have walked out on
and seen a bottom, but it did have fallen off at us all the whole day.
Sorry that you get to conflate controllers mad,
because you didn't get back to the limon time.
Thank you.